people have the right to freely
associate in private and to join
together as private membership groups
you might not want to join a cannabis
club but you certainly cannot stop
people from doing that On January 1st
2014 recreational marijuana became legal
in Colorado there's just one small
problem people can buy it they can use
it but in a lot of cases they don't have
anywhere where they can use it legally
that's right weed is legal in Colorado
but it's illegal to use it in any public
location it's become a huge issue for a
state that's attracting record numbers
of tourists who are curious to try
cannabis but have no safe legal place to
do so in fact public consumption
citations rose 471 percent in the first
year of legalization and fines average
$100 per ticket local business owner
Ryan Connolly says he noticed the
problem when out-of-towners began to
come to his store looking for help once
customers started buying legal weed they
would come to our store and shop for
clothes and always asks us the question
since we're locals where can I smoke
this and this question started to happen
more and more
where we actually just couldn't really
ignore it anymore so Ryan who runs the
grass roots clothing store and is the
founder of a seven-ten cannabis cup
devised a solution using space in his
own store we created it into a private
member's break room that was a private
member base 21 or over word-of-mouth
membership club where you could consume
cannabis and it was a BYOB
establishment so you would go to the
dispensary and then now have your safe
place to smoke
I included a private club with the help
of Jeff Gard a Boulder attorney who had
successfully established private
marijuana clubs and several other
Colorado counties I did my homework on
it and I found out that there is an
exception to the Colorado Indoor Air Act
for private member clubs so the VFW the
odd fellows the Elks Club things of that
nature so every person that wants to
consume marijuana at the break room has
to join the membership has to be
approved by the people who are already
members and
then again their dues go solely to pay
for the overheads under this private
membership model ryan's break room tally
4000 members and just over a year even
stars like Cheech Marin stop by when
visiting Denver to use the facility the
private pop Club operated without
incident until one weekend in April the
government resistance to 4/20 was pretty
strong already but strangely enough
became a much more concerted organized
effort by the city of Denver this year
after marijuana had been legalized and
among these things also a decision was
made by the Denver Police Department as
well as the City Attorney's Office to
crack down on private membership clubs
and among those clubs that were targeted
was my clients Club and so what happens
is officers sort of doing their homework
about this found out about the club and
then posing as prospective members they
basically lied their way into the club
on 419 I want to say around like five or
six o'clock I saw about fifteen or
twenty plainclothes officers come in and
at first they were you know a little
aggressive but weren't too bad but they
were like you know why we're here
when they got back there they kind of I
think we're a little surprised to find
that this is a private membership club
that they had to sign up as members to
become part of it that there wasn't
anything going on from the perspective
of the breakroom that was arguably
illegal though Denver police did not
charge any of the members of the crime
they cited Ryan for operating a
marijuana business without a license and
for violating the Clean Indoor Air Act
you know it's stressful because we tried
to do everything in our power to
separate the two two different staffs
two different point-of-sale systems
which is interesting the police counted
our money went through our point-of-sale
system and
take any of it I believe truly that they
did not think we were actually sewing
anything but Ryan's war dealed in it and
their after citing him for licensing
violations the city went one step
further and threatened Ryan's landlord
with a public nuisance abatement if they
didn't evict him from the premises
you know the eviction is what hurts the
most we have over 20 staff that I want
to make sure we keep jobs for all of
them Ryan appeared in court in July and
paid his fines when we visited he was in
the middle of packing up his business
and looking for a new location to move
his store though Ryan lost his space
he's hopeful that this experience will
bring about a change in the current law
I think it's you know the people's
choice now to step up and look at these
instances where they're still wasting
our taxpayers money and going after
something you would think would be you
know a respectable thing to do which is
offer someone from out of state a safe
place to smoke people who have similar
interests and similar hobbies or
whatever have the right to freely
associate in private and to join
together as private membership groups
you might not want to join a cannabis
club but you certainly cannot stop
people from doing that
as Ryan moves forward a debate is now
unfolding between Marijuana Policy
advocates and city leaders on how to
address the public consumption issue
Denver's office of marijuana policy says
amendment 64 clearly states that
marijuana is only to be used for private
and personal use and that the initiative
was not designed to accommodate tourists
but that hasn't stopped visitors or
local residents from consuming pot in
public which is why Mason Tiverton
Marijuana Policy Project is hoping a
compromise can be reached we don't want
a separate but equal system here we want
adults who enjoy using marijuana to be
able to associate with adults who enjoy
using alcohol and as long as it's only
people 21 and older there's really
shouldn't be a problem with that the
majority of people are not scofflaws we
understand that their rules are
necessary for ordered Society so just
tell us where to go tell us where we can
do this and we will go do that and it
makes perfect sense that if you want to
quit writing public consumption tickets
if you want to have a positive image if
you will and from the perspective the
government
you know that marijuana is not the only
thing that's going on in Colorado right
now then creating a private environment
for that is makes perfect sense
[Music]
you
[Music]